so you know when you get that call and
you're super excited to talk to the
person and you just go
can you only get 70 of the call that's
this show
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up what up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show
glad you're here to hang out grab a
drink have a seat
or keep walking or mowing your yard
whatever it is you're doing
james likes me to change up the front of
the show like the front it's not even
called the front it's called the start
of the show
because it's not a human or or a pet or
a car the start of the show
and he'll say something like hey listen
you say the same thing in the beginning
of every show and it's kind of annoying
don't do that anymore
and then i'm like all right don't do it
don't do it don't do it and then i just
do it because i'm thinking about it so i
need to stop
and he also said go back and change and
put on our same color shirts again
because today was black and gray plaid
day
it's like you know counselors give you
the advice don't don't give kids too
many instructions at once like young
kids especially boys i see what you're
doing they only hear the first thing
why did you have to gender this you
would what a jerk man i wore the same
clothes
i'm saying the things you tell me to no
you're saying things i tell you not to
say
see you're getting all specific now and
it's making me uncomfortable that's all
we're talking about
so hey we're so glad you're here if you
want to be on the show
and who wouldn't want to be on this show
because it is it is
wait we are straight driving here man we
are
this is a a a straight shooting show
right
pew pew um if you want to be on the show
we talk about relationships mental
health your marriage what's going on
um being well being not well what to do
next give me a call
at 1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
if you like seeing a grown-up
be berated like a child by the
people who aren't really his boss but
who can ruin my life
right and it's a weird tension they
don't send my paychecks
but if they want to i would never get
one again
that's kind of how it works um okay a
couple of cool things number one
um i've got to get better about this i'm
super weird
about selling stuff i hate it
but the reality is um that's how my kids
eat that's how i eat
my wife too it's how we all eat and
here's the thing
this is important this book is good and
it's short and i don't want to be that
guy but it is so
if you are struggling with anxiety if
you know someone who's struggling with
anxiety
check this book out it's called
redefining anxiety you can get it at
johndaloni.com
ramseysolutions.com it's
the the it's done so much better than
anybody dreamt it would do not because
it's not good not because we didn't
think it was
it was a great product but because it
struck a nerve with folks and there
tens and tens of thousands of people are
circling back to us saying
for the first time somebody said things
in a way i can understand in a simple
way
and in a direct way and now we can
actually start tackling this thing that
is anxiety so
um go to johndeloney.com and check this
out and while you're there
um here's the deal i hear this a lot
i i've got anxiety i'm struggling
but more than that i'm just sitting on
the couch watching tv i'm just driving
home from work i'm just
i gotta uh give a presentation at work
in the next 30 minutes
and then bam my anxiety alarms go off
i'm stressing i'm kind of wigging out a
little bit
and i don't know what to do at that
point i developed a
guided meditation it's about 10 or so
minutes
and it is me walking you through step by
step slow down
and it's a it's a cross between a
meditation
and a guided relaxation relaxation
right a couple exercises in there but
here's the thing i'm gonna walk you
through breathing exercises show you how
to lean in
listen get calm find healing
just quiet those alarms down and then
you can go on to the next thing you got
lined up
so go to johndaloni.com it is totally
free
i'm not going to charge anybody for this
it's something that
is is important man i need someone to
walk alongside as i am
learning how to learn some new skills to
learn some
new ways of controlling my thoughts
slow my body down listen to these alarms
and then go make the next right thing so
go to johndaloni.com
d-e-l-o-n-y download the free guided
meditation while you're there 10 bucks
grab a copy of the redefining anxiety
and start to reclaim your heart and your
mind
so let's go to the phones let's go
straight through let's go to susan in
greenville south carolina
susan what's going on hi
great to talk to you it's so good to
talk to you i'm looking
thank you i'm looking for some
suggestions on how to better support my
husband
we've been married for 30 years he
is bipolar and currently he's on a
really good treatment plan
good medical care but a few years ago
he had a very bad manic episode that
lasted several months
he actually left did some very bad
behavior
but we got past that but about once a
year or so
he goes through a time where he just
wants to stop his medication
usually i find out three or four days
after he started this he doesn't hide it
but he doesn't
tell me i mean i usually find out about
it he's not
necessarily trying to hide it but when
he does that
that's when i have you know what i think
is an overreaction i kind of have a
freak out
with that and i'm just trying to find
out how to better react to that
because i know it's periodically going
to happen and
how i can help him manage that better
i'm sorry i know this is hard right
living for those of you who don't live
with somebody with bipolar
it's really hard because when they are
on
on when they're well when they are
working their treatment plan
they're pretty miraculous people to be
around aren't they
yes very much so like they can
the folks with bipolar that i've known
who are on their treatment plan
they almost have a an ability to see
into you right and to experience you and
to love in a way and they can receive
love and
it's it's almost magic and then when
they go
up or down it's it's a whiplash right
because
you don't know who's real who's not and
um
so tell me about this episode that
um scared you to death
um well like i said he actually left um
just kind of went very manic um
for those who don't know what that means
what does very manic mean he
kind of went off the deep end i guess um
very suddenly
so what does that mean i mean like with
okay within a few within
a couple weeks time he left me just
completely left
um started getting involved in some
very negative behaviors um drinking
sexual behaviors yeah um and so forth
and so why'd you take him back finally
when he came home
i mean he was remorseful he's a he's a
wonderful man i mean he's worth it
you know i love him he's my soul mate
and he was did all one of the conditions
was that he
get on a good treatment plan or at least
start that process you know better
medical management yeah and he's done
that
um you know and he's he's worth it
definitely how long were you married to
him you've been together 30 years how
long were you married to him before you
y'all realized this what was going on
um bipolar probably about 10 years ago i
mean we were married quite a long time
so is there 20 years of unprocessed
trauma
before that um
to where you were alive you have some
issues with depression
i would say are you talking about me or
him i
if he was on the phone we could talk
about him but i'm talking about you what
i what i experience a lot is folks who
love people with bipolar who don't know
what that is
there's a there's a a a lifetime there's
a
years and years of really tough trauma
because
everybody's looking for reasons why
there's a depressive episode or why
there's manic episodes or
why there's these rich lovely relational
moments in between
and that you end up the partner ends up
taking the brunt of that
right right and you know for years i
thought i may be responsible for the
depression
you know what had i done or what how had
i done
anything to affect that before he was
diagnosed yep
um so do you have kids i finally
realized that's not me
i'm grown yes no no young children okay
all right so there's nobody in the house
that
we need to keep saying no okay no no no
so did you quote unquote
to use your words did you freak out
before this
big episode or is this new
for you um no this is new this
is totally related back to that okay
cool so
i want you i have a fear that that's
going to happen again yes yes yes and so
it's important for you to know you're
not bananas
okay you're not coming unglued here
you're not broken
you have a very visceral real experience
of what happens
when he doesn't follow the treatment
plan you've been on the receiving end of
that right
and so when you start to when you see
hey it's day four or five he hadn't
taken his meds
he's trying to get louder and more you
know starting to get buzzy or
suddenly he doesn't go to work you come
home and he's still in bed and all of a
sudden those alarms spin up in you
i want you to know your body and mind
are working perfectly
right you're not broken busted in or
anything you can learn some new things
but you're not busted because you saw it
happen that one time
okay okay and so walk me through what
your
you'll have most treatment plans have a
i wish this wasn't such dramatic
language but have a battle a plan of
attack
if you notice something not right you'll
have that already ironed out
um i mean as far as i can call his
doctor
you know that's an agreement okay are
you part of that treatment plan
can the doctor call you yes yes awesome
awesome okay yeah we have a really good
good medical care right now
very cool okay so are you anticipating
is
are we getting close to the season when
he stops taking his meds
um are you just coming off that season a
few months ago yeah you're just coming
off of it all right so tell me tell me
what happened recently
um well it was probably right over just
after christmas which is always a rough
time for him
um and i just you know i notice i
i do his medications for him you know i
put them out and i noticed
all of a sudden there was like three
days
more than there should have been and i
question him and he
always admits it and he always has a
reason he was either feeling extra tired
and it doesn't make him feel good
because and i recognize that it is a
down because he's not he doesn't have
that high
um and usually he is agreeable to
go back on it and talk to his doctor
so he does the right things once i
confront him about it
but i have that initial freak out where
i'm just like how could you you know do
this we talked about this
you know sure and i don't want to have
that reaction i don't want to
i love it i'd like to get past that part
of it so do you function as his mom
like when you say like i do his pills
for him and stuff why do you do that
um it's easier honestly he gets mixed up
with it and it's
does he choose to get mixed up no
honestly no
it's not a choice that he makes he he'll
take the wrong thing daytime or night he
it's just it's difficult for him okay so
sometimes i do feel like a mother or a
nurse
you know i yeah and i want to be a wife
yeah see that at some point
you've been the other 30 years right so
we're not talking and we're three years
in and we're gonna
change the trajectory here you all have
been together a long long time
and so at some point my fear for you is
you're gonna get exhausted being
a mom your kids are grown right and
you're gonna get tired of
wiping booties and wiping counters and
getting pills ready every day i
i have to believe that's a behavior that
if he needed to learn
he could maybe not maybe the depth of
his bipolar is
is what it is can he hold the job oh
definitely yeah he's a very hard worker
even on his worst days he always works
hard what's his truth
um he's in construction so he can build
things
yeah 100 chance he could deal with his
meds if he chose to
and i think have you ever processed with
a professional
the trauma that you experienced or did
y'all go straight to how can we help
him to never do this again that was more
yeah that was more focus on him and
trying to fix that so uh here's i'll
give you a
totally new analogy for you to to to
maybe see this in a new light okay
so okay let's say my um five-year-old
daughter
she gets a tummy ache in the middle of
the night she comes in my room
and she says daddy i don't feel good and
i wake up and i'm like what wait what
and then she just barfs all over me
right all over the bed i can't get
mad at her i can get frustrated i can
get so
upset and like ugh gross but i'm not
gonna get mad because she was hurting
and she went to the one place that she
knew
right then next time i'm gonna put a
bowl in there in her room right or i'm
gonna talk to her about hey when you get
sick go throw up in the bathroom and
then come get me
right and she said great daddy and then
she came and barfed on me again and
barfed on me again and barfed him again
then i'm gonna get mad right now you're
just barfing on me
and i want you to follow this plan like
i need you
to learn this skill right
and at some point i'm gonna feel really
guilty for being mad at my sick kid
i'm gonna feel i'm gonna say something
in the middle of the night when somebody
barfs on me that i'm gonna be
ashamed about right i'm gonna i'm gonna
have to deal with the fact that i didn't
like how i handled this
i don't like being barfed on and i've
got somebody who's not doing well in my
house right so it's
all of these things all at once so
when somebody's got bipolar and they're
a grown-up
and they you have been working with them
at this point for 20 years 25 years
and then this happens some out of the
blue
alcohol drug sexual misconduct all this
stuff happens
you can rationalize in your head hey my
husband's not well
and he's gonna follow this plan and then
he jumps on it's all about solving him
and making sure he does the right thing
and you work with a doctor i've got
these rules
and they're all there but you've also
got to deal with the fact that
you've really been busting your butt for
years and even did that and that
hurts and you got really mad
and that hurts and every time you think
it's going to happen again
it hurts right every time my daughter
comes in at 3am i'm going to jump up
thinking she's going to barf on me again
right
and so what i want you to do is if you
want to stop the overreaction number one
you have to choose and say i'm not going
to overreact
i'm not going to i chose to take him
back
i chose that and so now i'm going to
learn some new skills which is what
you're doing which is why you're brave
and i'm so glad you called
i really want to recommend that you go
deal with you and not in a bad way but
you gotta learn some new skills you
gotta
grieve this marriage you thought you
were gonna have that you never have
dealt with
you're gonna have to grieve the fact
that your husband is somebody that right
now
you've got to like put his medicine out
for him like he's a child
and then you're going to discover your
voice
you're going to discover these things
that you know what i want in this
relationship and i think you can
get and then you can begin to work with
him
on hey we've been together 30 years
you're 50 years old
it's time for you to learn how to take
your medication the right way i love you
and you are all in i'm going to teach
you
and we are going to work together but i
want to be your wife
i want to be um you know we're halfway
done with life right i want to be
recklessly in love with you i want to
have so much fun
and part of that is i want to stop being
your mom and we're going to learn how to
do this together
right and that comes from a place of
making meaning from the grieving that
you're going to have to do
that comes from a place of you having to
learn some new tools to move forward
all that starts with i'm not freaking
out anymore i'm not gonna give him my
freak out i'm not gonna give him my
character
so the moment you see he hadn't taken
his medication you know what
what's gonna happen that's when you're
going to have a setup of
skills you're going to have a set of
people to call you're going to have a
i'm going to go for a walk i'm going to
head out
i'm going to i'm going to download this
guided meditation john delorean.com i'm
going to go out there
and i'm going to consciously bring
myself down i'm going to take 24 hours
and then i'm going to circle back
because i know he doesn't not like me i
know he doesn't hate me i know he's not
trying to be ugly
he's not well right he's got some
significant challenges
he didn't throw up on me on purpose but
it happened again
and so i'm going to lean back in but i'm
not going to give him that and that's
going to start
with you going to find somebody to get
well so i want you to hear me say this
susan
you're worth being a wife and not a mom
and you're worth being loved
and you're worth grieving this
marriage that you've held together more
than likely for
30 plus years and it doesn't mean you're
going to leave him it doesn't mean it's
going to get all sideways now it means
your voice is going to finally
be heard probably for the first time in
a long long time so thank you so so much
for that call let's go to peter in
bloomington
peter what's up my man hey doc john how
are you
good man what's going on with you oh
well
um my wife and i are at a crossroads
with our church
and we're we're trying to decide as to
whether we should stay
and uh but we're not in agreement on it
oh okay so what's going on with your
church yeah hey uh talking talking to
your phone man
yeah i'm trying sorry i had to get the
list on my on my ride home
okay um sorry no you're good what's up
so it's a church i've been
no i just lost you peter you still there
yeah i'm here are you there oh there you
go okay let's try it again all right so
go ahead okay if i'm going in now sorry
so this is a church
i've been to since i was a young boy i'm
an adult now with kids
okay and we had a pastor change about
four years ago
and there have been some
disagreements on the way
things should work there's been little
hurts there's been a little offenses
um and it's like you're talking about
you're talking pretty vague
like little hurts little fences pointed
at your wife at the church community
what
do you what who's hurt and what well
so our pastor came in and is
is i don't know how it says the initial
offense was with my wife she was
she had lost a close family member and
no one from the church leadership really
reached out to her did anything like
that okay and so that was a deep seed
hurt
there are some very progressive
attitudes yeah
from our our leadership regarding um
race and taking offenses at
different decorations um
here they've brought into the church
that i've disagreed with okay
and again it's not all bad it just seems
like it's little
cuts here and there that keep building
and and my wife has had enough
and i would like to stay and work
through it
and i know i'm not a grasses greener
kind of guy so i understand that
nowhere is going to be perfect but it's
caused quite a bit of stress in our
relationship in the last year or so
and we're trying to figure out how to
work through it together gotcha
so this is less about when do you leave
a church
and more about how do you and your wife
come together to make decisions for the
both of you right
yeah i guess i mean it's all been
centered around the church so
yeah yeah that's i mean that's the easy
neon sign to point at
um so what it what is it
that you want to stick around for
well i still have family there um
uh again the there's gonna be a stress
in leaving that church and finding
another church and
getting and you know establishing
relationships that way
um why does she want to leave she just
tired
she's tired of listening to you is she
tired of
every week it's another thing that
you're upset about and she's like let's
just go
or is she saying if i keep going to this
place
um i'm going to continue to be
uncomfortable
uh yes some of that um
i i seem to have a beef more often than
not with something that's happened or
something that's been said most of her
friends are gone
at church now a lot of people have left
our church
uh since the new pastor has come um
uh so let me ask you this what is that
what does
winning look like here or let me ask you
this
yeah let me back it up before that
you talk about there's new attitudes on
progressive thought there's new
attitudes on race there's new attitudes
on hey we're gonna do things differently
are you interested in sitting down and
learning new things tell me about why
this is
or are you more interested in this is
the way this is supposed to be
y'all are not doing it the way it's
supposed to be done and i'm going to be
here
and i'm going to engage with this
community until we get it back to the
way it's supposed to be
what are your two that's kind of a
binary choice which one are where are
you
well i've certainly had to swallow my
own pride and
willingness
say that again you've swallowed your own
pride in what
yeah i lost you man
are you still there yeah there we go so
you had to swallow your own pride in
yeah i've had to learn new things
and i've had to accept that but at the
same time
i think there are certain foundational
things i'm not willing to move on
and i've resisted that spoke to my
pastor
about it so per se
um so yeah i guess i'm kind of a little
bit of both
okay sounds like you
i mean there's one or two choices man it
sounds like your wife is tired of
either her husband hurting tired of her
husband's
whining about it or tired of
um not being in any sort of agreement
and so she's like man let's just go
somewhere else
and this is a place that you're probably
pretty well summed up okay
and you've got deep-seated roots here
you love this place you love what it's
been about more importantly you love
what it has meant
to you meant past tense
and now it is you're looking to
what the future's going to look like and
you don't know what that's going to look
like
and here's here's what i tell you man
this ends up
at some point with you leaving or are
you running a minister out of town
and nobody feels good on the back end of
that either
right and those are my only two choices
i mean what's the third choice
give me the way we're going give me what
a win is going to look like for you
that one day your your pastor's going to
call you in and be like you know what
man
you're right i'm wrong let's go back to
the way it was
i'm going to do a couple of sermons on
how to how to go back
you know i mean like what what do you
think the wind looks like
well for the sake of sounding arrogant
i'm hopeful my wife can
address some of her hurts and grow past
it and form
just but
say it one more time
yeah i lost you man um
so here's the thing um
when you find yourself in a place where
a community is moving
one direction or the other from you and
you have learned some new things but
there's also a lines that you're not
going to cross
whatever that may be right let me i'm
trying to think of one that's non
it's not a third rail um thinking about
like
learning math my my son i started
teaching him the
the way i learned math which evidently
isn't cool anymore
and it's not the right way to teach a
kid how to do math my son is so much
better at math than i was
and my wife attributes that to new
teaching models and math
and at first i was like oh they're just
messing with these kids these days
back in the old days i had to memorize
the facts and whatever and my wife's
like how'd that work out for you and i
was like well played
and so i sat down and had my son teach
me a few new things
and i thought man that's really good and
i did think man there's just some stuff
you got to memorize
right you just got to memorize that 9
times 9 is 81 right you just got to
memorize some stuff
but at the end of the day i'm not
teaching math i'm not absorbed in it i'm
i'm stepping out of that conversation
i'm not going to engage with it anymore
i trust my teachers that are
the teachers are teaching my son and
then they're moving on with it right
and so at some point you got to say hey
this community's moved on to a different
place right wrong or indifferent i'm
going to mourn it and grieve it and then
i'm going gonna go
create a new community wishing your wife
would change the way she feels change i
don't think it has to do with
getting over her issues man i think it
has to do with
she's tired of listening to you she's
tired of every sunday
the church is supposed to be a place
where we go all say hey we're all broken
we're all screwed up and we all look at
each other and go oh man me too
you two and everybody exhales
and everybody locks arms and then we go
serve the least of these
we feed the homeless we take care of the
poor
and then we go about our week and then
we circle back and
when church turns into fights and
yelling
and let's let's go to war against
everyone else
man it's just it's not what it was
designed to be
and so my guess is your wife's done with
that part of it
and man i'm gonna tell you you're
you can go to war with them man try to
get the guy fired
try to bring your church back to its
roots and
make some changes and you can do that
and if you find
peace in that then so be it
my thought on when it's time to leave a
church is this
when they're no longer upholding their
mission to care for widows and orphans
when they spend more money on the church
show on the lasers
and the smoke than they are on actually
serving others
when their identity becomes one of a
fighting culture other people other
churches
fighting takes precedence over cups of
water feeding orphans taking care of the
least of these
that's when me and my fam that's when
we're out right
that's when we're out when church
becomes a show when it becomes a
performance
um that's when we're gonna step away it
also is a place where we hold each other
accountable right we have hard
conversations
but if we wait until these last few
moments to do that if we wait until
these third rail political
man it's already lost it so i don't know
if that answers your question brother
i'm sorry i lost you there but
um it sounds to me like y'all are done
and i'd love to sit have you sit down
with your wife and say i think i want to
go find another place
where would you like to go and then just
go visit some other places man try it
and see what that'll look like for you
all right let's take one more call let's
go to
uh ellie in philadelphia ellie what's
going on
hello hey ellie what's up hey i'm sorry
my phone cut out for a second there um
no that's good how are you i'm doing
well thank you and you
very very good very good so what's up
so my my main question for you today is
my my husband and i are not seeing eye
to eye on um
on a specific issue and i am of two
minds as to whether
i need to dig my heels in and really try
to drive my point home
or if i just need to kind of throw up my
hands and say
all right well this is part of your
grieving process so i'm just gonna be
here while you work it out okay
go for it so back in
november my husband lost his brother in
a uh
in a car accident and it was sudden and
nobody saw it coming and it hit him
really really hard i'm so sorry yeah
thank you um so so with that
um as
as my brother-in-law's um estate is
finally starting to come in the line and
we're starting
to figure out how it's going to be you
know taken care of essentially there's
this one item
uh it's this race car
this is what it is race cars
yeah my my brother-in-law like he he was
like a minor celebrity in our community
and like one of his things was he would
take the car down to the track and
win these races and things and cool
so yeah i mean it's not i'm a huge
i'm a huge fan of both minor like minor
celebrities in towns i love that that
makes me so happy
and i love ricky bobby and so you have
just met my heart on two different
fronts and so
i am so grateful that you called today
okay so
your brother-in-law was a minor celeb
which i
love love small town minor celeb race
car driver
and he passed away suddenly in a car
wreck unrelated
and then you and your hovering husband
are having a disagreement
yes because my husband wants to buy out
his the rest of his siblings for this
car and i just feel like it's a bad idea
why does he want to buy the race car uh
well when i
uh of the previous times that we've
talked about it he's he tells me that
you know he really wants to
get the car and do further modifications
to it that he knew that his brother
wanted them but didn't get a chance to
and he wants to take it down and do the
racing and that kind of
thing is he a car guy is he a car racer
guy
well ish and that's that's part of why i
have my reservations because if you were
even like a casual racer i probably
wouldn't even raise my eyebrows
but the last time he took one of his own
cars
to the racetrack was like 2018.
okay and so why why does are his brother
and sisters
like why don't they just give him the
car if it means a lot to him why don't
they just give it to him
uh it's just a question of well because
my my brother-in-law passed away he
didn't have a will so it's just a
question of like who
all that legal stuff is what they're
waiting on okay does he have a family
too that's that's parsing through
everything
uh no he he died single okay all right
so is it is the question about the money
is it about
his safety what is your concern here
it's it's partially money and it's also
partially just like i'm not really
understanding why he's so hung up about
the car because like i said he's not
even a casual racer um oh the car has
nothing to do with racing
oh i i figured that much but it's just i
don't know i feel like sometimes he kind
of
throughout this whole process he's
latched on to some odd
in my opinion odd mementos of his
brother like
you know his brother had asthma do we
want to keep his medical equipment and
i'm looking at my husband like why would
we want to keep his medical equipment
when either one of us has asthma
yeah so did he love his brother
very much they were they were very close
they're pretty close how old
how far apart were they in age uh
five years but like they were like my my
husband's the the second youngest and
the brother that passed away was the
baby of the family
uh okay so they had to they had to grind
it out together down there at the bottom
right
yeah how um how old is your husband
he is uh turning 39. okay
so every single thing that he gives away
that you all get rid of is
a little is one more piece of your of
your brother-in-law that's turning into
a vapor
every little piece and so you can look
at that at that
um asthma equipment and go
why would we need a nebulizer
and your husband doesn't hear that at
all
that represents a little piece of his
brother and we sell the nebulizer we
give that nebulizer away
and then there goes another little piece
and then another little piece
and the thing about race cars the thing
about
modific modifying the thing about racing
is now you've got a project you've got a
spirit that we're gonna keep alive
not in things but you can never fill
that thing
right it's about making meaning finding
meaning on the back end of this deal
and it's gonna be we're gonna keep going
right we're gonna keep going we're gonna
keep going i'm gonna do these things
and man a few months out people can
spend a lot of money
you hear about people burning through
their inheritances that way they go do
some daredevil things
um i've heard of veterans who will go
try to relive something
to honor a lost uh fellow soldier that
so man people can
really go to some great links to try to
make meaning try to find meaning but
really what they're trying to do is is
they're trying to say i don't want to
say goodbye
and the longer i can keep this alive the
longer there's there's
the person i loved and i lost to stand
with me
have you how has your husband grieved
this loss
uh we well we we've run like the full
gamut of grieving in our household we've
you know done the crying and the
screaming and the the irritability
and for for most of it i've kind of just
kind of
sat back and just let him work through
what he's working through
um but it's just with this car like you
know we
we have a one-car garage and no driveway
so like where are you even going to work
on it you know that sort of thing
and so what i want you to do is not try
to have
no that's not fair it's going to say
don't try to have rational conversations
because this isn't a rational project
does that make sense no i i picked up on
that and that's part of my frustration
because i don't know how to
because out of the two of us i'm much
more the more practical one so i don't
really know how to
right so handle all this stuff
so let's see what numbers are getting
thrown around
like a purchase price well the
the purchase price so much isn't the
issue it's only about like three to four
thousand dollars i think
okay um my concern with the price is
mostly
you know um the cost of the
modifications that he wants to do and
then we're looking at
upping our um car insurance because we
already have
three vehicles now we're adding a fourth
um
okay and then like i said just just the
storage issue because we have
you know most most of our cars are you
know parked down on the street right now
because of you know the town we live in
yeah so it's not like you know it's not
like we have a nice big suburban
house with multi-car garages and
driveways you can do whatever you want
so one thing that takes down couples
that most people never fully grasp until
it happens to them
is what i would call competitive
grieving
meaning for some people somebody passes
away suddenly in november
it is a hard hard thanksgiving christmas
season
really hard and then january is a little
bit lighter
february is the gray months but we're
starting to make peace with what
happened here we're starting to pick up
the pieces
and then all of a sudden someone's
walking alongside us and they just fall
off
right and suddenly it's like dude will
you just
like we know this is a big deal but we
all got to get up tomorrow and they
don't seem like they can get up
right and so one thing i always want
couples to
be graceful with one another and is that
balance between you gotta get up and go
to work you gotta get up and do these
things and
man and
everybody grieves differently if it's 3
000
bucks and he can come up with a storage
plan that's one that
here's the thing he's not going to work
on it you know that i know that
he may race it once in some big ceremony
maybe
maybe right i think after like the
one-year anniversary or
yeah it'll be a thing right and so for 3
000
you could that's that's money right but
the
the reality is once this estate gets
settled your brothers and his brothers
and sisters aren't going to charge them
3000 bucks you're going to give them the
car
and if they do charge them 3 000 bucks
come on guys let them have the car for
crying out loud you aren't going to do
anything with it
and if he can come up with a storage
plan
that's not going to break the bank this
that's gonna be well thought out so
that's where you can put some of this on
him because some of this
is a fantasy it's a myth it's a way to
keep a ghost at the table
and every time you say okay hey make me
a plan for what this will actually look
like
how are we going to afford this here's
our budget here's the reality of the
money we have here's what the track
cost here's what running the cars at the
track scouts and those are expensive
right the tires and all stuff's really
expensive
make me a plan for how we're going to do
this
and then some of that may just fall away
right and that may be a heartbreaking
reality moment for him where he realizes
we can't afford to do this
or he may circle back and say hey billy
bob down the street is going to let us
store the car there it's 3 000 bucks i
can pay for it
um we can pay for this can i just do
this and for 300 bucks sure high five
way to go
and then we're going to budget every
month and we're going to not just go buy
bumpers and new i don't i'm gonna start
talking carburetors i'm trying to sound
like a car guy which i'm
super not um we can't get out of control
because we're gonna have this
constrained budget here
or you can
ask him to come up with a broader plan
for everything all at once
and then you can say are you scared to
let your brother go
because he loved you and i want us to
work towards letting him go
be in peace right and it may still mean
you end up with a race car in your
driveway for a season so be it
but it also may mean that he's gonna do
the hard work of grieving so here's one
thing i do want you all to do together
i want you to get david kessler's book
finding meaning it's the best book on
grief i've ever read and i want you all
to read it together
james will put it in the show notes here
it's by david kessler it's called
finding meaning
it's a masterpiece but it's something
you all can read together and it will
give
you the opportunity to ask him some hard
questions that are going to come from
the book not from him
and it's a really clean easy read
and it's not anything complicated or
hard but it's going to let him express
some of his thoughts and some of his
feelings
and if making meaning is hey once a year
i pull this thing out of the driveway
and it's three thousand bucks
man i don't care about that you know
what you don't have a space in your
garage right so that is a thing right
but if it comes down to i don't care
about three thousand bucks four thousand
dollars for
to hang on to something for my brother
that's not a big deal in the grand
scheme of things
if it is i'm gonna go mortgage the house
and do these things that's when you as
his partner in life
as somebody who mutually helps hold him
accountable or he holds you accountable
we can't afford to do this we're not
gonna go bankrupt in the memory of your
brother
that's not going to be a good
stewardship of his memory that's going
to drive us underwater
and that's not a good way to remember
your brother
but this book is going to give you all a
step-by-step process to walk through
that so
i know that's so messy everybody out
there this has been hard with covet too
right this has been really hard with
kovitt this idea of
grieving together my wife and i grieve
differently at different paces at
different speeds and different ways
man that's hard we've been together a
long time
a way to cut through that is to say hey
is this about this car
is this about your brother or are you
really sad
that your brother's not with us anymore
are you really sad that you had this
business that just went away
are you really sad that somebody
betrayed you
because man then all of a sudden getting
angry doesn't make a lot of sense
just sitting here and the suck of it for
a while does
and then i'm gonna walk with you
tomorrow cause we gotta get up we gotta
shower we gotta go to work
right but it's about just
grieving and we all do it and it sucks
and it's a part of life which is why we
need each other right so i need zach and
james and kelly all of our friends my
wife so we need each other
because hard things happen thank you so
much for that call ellie i'm
um man i'm grateful for you that you
called um
here's the thing i'm gonna throw a
curveball here as we wrap up the show
i had one song but
i was gonna go a little bit dark and i'm
not
the first time i heard this song was in
one of in elementary school
during one of those uh it was like
a show we did in the elementary school
like a stage and it was like a
we all danced in the same way we didn't
dance so we all moved
and we had the same movements and i
think her name was michelle frazier she
ended it with a round off flip-flop was
the
awesomest thing i'd ever seen in third
grade she looked like an acrobat it was
incredible
she was a wonderful human being but this
song we had to like do all these like
movements together like
it was so great i think this was the
song it probably isn't even the song but
i'm gonna pretend it was okay so in 1988
the one and only right the og queen
of earth whitney houston
released an album it was actually the
1988 summer olympics album
right
one moment in time whitney drops this
gems check this out everybody each day i
live i want to be
a day to give the best of me imagine a
bunch of third graders all moving on
arms at the same time
i'm only one but not alone my finest day
is yet unknown i broke my heart i fought
every gain to taste the sweet i faced
the pain
this sounds like a crossfit song i rise
and fall
yet through it all this much remains
now it's super not crossfit it's like a
weird breakup song i want
one one moment in time when i'm more
than i thought i could be
when all of my dreams are a what a
heartbeat away
and the answers are all up to me come on
man
give me one moment of time this is the
line when i'm racing with destiny
i don't even know what that means then
in that one moment of time
i will feel i will feel eternity
if you can solve that riddle ladies and
gentlemen
you're the smartest person alive this
has been the dr john dolone show
[Music]
you